good these are very serious times we're
facing the first anniversary tomorrow of
the Ukraine war of Putin's barbaric
invasion of Ukraine what is your reading
of where we are in the war first of all
right I think we've got to first of all
salute the courage of the Ukrainian
people lives buildings have all been
destroyed but the spirit of the
Ukrainian people has been indestructible
Hearts have been broken but I think
their courage has been unbreakable so I
think the first thing we've got to say
is that unexpected perhaps a year ago is
the sheer resilience and the willingness
to fight back as we've seen with
president zielinski but all the
Ukrainian people and the second thing I
think is clear is that the unity of of
the West has been maintained so America
and Europe and NATO adding Sweden and
Finland have been working together NATO
Unity of course there's big issues about
fighter jets and big issues about tanks
but the unity has held I I think there
were thing is that the rest of the world
has not woken up to the seriousness of
the aggression that has been practiced
by Putin we've got to persuade the rest
of the world that this is a turning
point if we do not support the Ukrainian
people against uh the Putin assault then
people will think that they can practice
aggression with impunity and that's why
I'm wanting Putin to be brought to
Justice that's why I favor a special
tribunal that's why the ICC the
international criminal court will not be
able to do the job because it cannot try
the crime of aggression against Ukraine
but we can all get together like at
Nuremberg and have a special tribunal
where Putin and his cabal would be
brought to trial we're both in America
you're in Texas I'm in New York a lot of
that decision making will depend on
America's support do you think that
President Biden will go along with what
you would like to do
well I think it's been remarkable that
President Biden has visited Ukraine this
week and I think he should be
congratulated I know you did in your
columns and in your television
interviews say that this was a very
special uh thing that Biden did a year
on and I think it's important that he
sent that message both to the Ukrainian
people and to the rest of Europe that he
was 100 behind uh president zielinski
and what he was trying trying to do but
you know the whole of Europe the
European Parliament the European Union
the Europe Council of Europe the Nordic
countries the Baltic countries France
perhaps reluctantly to start Germany
perhaps reluctantly to start now the
United Kingdom they've all said a
special tribunal should be set up the
exception is still America you cannot
allow the crime of aggression in the
modern world to go with impunity you
cannot send out a message at that
there's a safe haven for those who
practice this you cannot allow there to
be a hiding place for criminals like
Putin and whatever is to happen in the
future it is absolutely clear that you
can prove that the crime of aggression
was initiated and practiced continues to
be practiced and of course the innocent
civilians rape mutilation all the
torture that has been carried out by
Russian soldiers that arises from the
foundational crime the crime of
aggression the one that was brought for
the Nazi war criminals in in 1946 and
the one that is relevant as a crime to
be prosecuted today so America I hope
will come along with Europe Europe has
gone with America on so many issues
America I think and President Biden
should use Friday should use the day to
say look this is the time when we'll add
the
judicial action to every everything else
that we're doing you had an
extraordinary first encounter with
Vladimir Putin at the Kremlin when you
were the chancellor of the executive in
the UK government 2006 and it was quite
chilling actually when you recounted
what happened there because he made you
sit in a smaller chair so that you had
to look up at him and then he started
reading you out all this information
about yourself
almost in a way to say I know about you
I know where you live buddy kind of
stuff
yeah yeah it was the old KGB agent and
as you know Putin is a small man he sits
at a desk above you you're in a city and
you're sort of sinking into that City so
you've got no choice but to look up at
him and he's issuing threats you know
we're going to sell our oil to to the
East and not to the West uh gas will
never come to Europe if you don't do
what we say and of course later if you
have an expansion of NATO there's going
to be retaliation what I understood
immediately now some people thought you
could do business with Putin I never
thought that what I understood
immediately was that this guy all he
understands is strength he'll exploit
any weakness totally opportunist in
doing so and you've got to send out a
message of strength and it's got to be
United in the way that you convey that
message and we had to deal with lip
venenko's assassination as you know on
the Streets of London we knew that Putin
we knew Putin was planning further
assassinations we had to send a very
strong message that we would retaliate
and we would not allow this to happen we
gave 24-hour protection to lots of
citizens that we knew were being
targeted for assassination he was going
to send other Killers into the country
and it was only 10 years later I think
when the guard had dropped we had been
protecting people the guard had dropped
that we saw the Salisbury killings there
taking place uh I I mean no doubt that
you cannot trust Putin he is not a man
of his word that he only understands
strength and it's strength that we've
got to show now his strength we've got
to show by unity you know he's making
deals with other countries to sell his
oil 50 of his oils now going to China
and to and to India you know that also
he is there's a naval exercise at the
moment in South Africa South African Air
Forces Chinese forces and Russian forces
the way that he is trying to build Iran
they're trying to build Syria trying to
build support with other countries is
something that we've got to we've got to
counter one of your successes as prime
minister Boris Johnson had as today come
out and said to Rishi sunak the current
prime minister that he must send fighter
jets to support Ukraine militarily and
also says China should be warned that it
would be an historic mistake if they
were to get involved directly on the
side of Vladimir Putin and Russia what's
your reaction to both of those things
well the worrying thing today is if the
American intelligence is correct and
China is considering giving physical
support to the to the Russian attack on
Ukraine now I don't know whether that
intelligence is has been proven to be
accurate and I don't know what the
Chinese plans are but clearly the
strongest possible message should be
sent I said a year ago that we were
bound to see a long War I'm afraid a
long war that we will see the decoupling
of Europe from Russia and that's
actually happening but the variable was
what China was going to do it was bound
to say it wasn't going to
really sort of criticize the sort of in
on all the Russia but it hasn't been
giving physical support so that's a very
serious development and we've got to
look at what's happening there now when
you look at the military support uh
President Biden as you know is drawing a
fine line and trying to get a fine
balance between support for Ukraine and
active engagement in a war he's trying
to get a balance between delivering uh
if you're like military and other
support and a declaration of war and I
understand from my own experience in
government that this is a fine line a
very difficult thing to do I don't think
there should be a red line about sending
fighter jets I think that's worthy of
consideration and should be considered
and I know Netherlands Poland France I
said that they're supportive of this but
we do know from Ben Wallace the defense
secretary of the UK that this will take
a time uh and and therefore it's not a
silver bullet it's not a Magic Bullet
we've got to look at how we can increase
the support for Grant to air
surveillance ground to air action to to
get rid of Russian Jets from from from
the air and obviously we've got to get
the tanks to people as quickly as
possible this is essentially I think
everybody agrees a ground war at the
moment and the most we can do at the
moment I think quickly is to get the
tanks that we promise to to Ukraine uh
to them as soon as soon as possible does
this end with Ukraine being compelled to
seed one inch of territory lost
to Russia Ukraine rightly is United
around the Integrity of Ukraine
Putin believes that Ukraine is part of
Russia these are two irreconcilable
positions we have got to weaken Putin
now there are many reasons why Putin is
a lot weaker now than he was a year ago
he thought that NATO would not be United
he didn't think that Finland and Sweden
would come along he didn't think the
sanctions would be effective he thought
we would treat them like previous
governments had treated the invasion of
the Crimea he is not able to sell his
oil and gas in the way that he has in
the future but he's still got reserves
Russia the Russian economy has not
collapsed and it's uh possibly going to
be growing faster than the United
Kingdom this year so he has managed to
survive some of the sanctions so far but
he is severely weakened the key thing
and this is why I'm supporting this
judicial action to bring him to trial in
The Hague and to say he is a war
criminal guilty of the crime of
aggression the key is to persuade the
whole of the world that this is a cry
time that is completely unacceptable in
the modern world it is possible to
imagine in his absence Putin being tried
in a few weeks time for the crime of
aggression it's adding to our Weaponry
if you like the military and the
material and the moral support at the
judicial weapon that was something that
has been used since Nuremberg to punish
war criminals Gordon Brown great to have
you making your debut on Piers Morgan
uncensored please come back soon really
enjoyed the conversation thank you
thank you peers